beware
the spiders we already knew that spiders
were going to be in hogwarts legacy
going off the first trailer when they
appeared for just a brief moment but not
a lot of people have been talking about
this in fact i think some people don't
want to be talking about it hoping that
spiders won't be in the game but i think
that this just about confirms it one of
the big questions among fans are these
acrimantula or a different type of
spider and if they are acromantula does
that break the canon of the original
series so if you're arachnophobe be
prepared don't worry i'm not going to
have any jump scares here but we will be
discussing those furry 8-legged
creatures today now i'll tell you what i
did i pulled out my copy of fantastic
beasts and where to find them no not the
movie the original school book which jk
rowling published all the way back in
2001 with a very large portion of that
going to charity from sales of the book
fantastic beasts and where to find them
of course was written by newt scamander
and represents the fruit of many years
travel and research when newt published
fantastic beasts acromanchiala received
the most severe ministry of magic
classification for magical beasts which
means they're considered known wizard
killers and impossible to train or
domesticate according to the book the
first recorded sighting of an
acromantula came in 1794 so they
definitely would have been around for
the time of hogwarts legacy which is
expected to take place in 1890. now
acromantula originated in borneo and
it's believed they are wizard bread
possibly bread to guard wizard dwellings
or treasure don't forget that bit right
there about guarding wizard dwellings or
treasure we're going to come back to
that another distinct quality of the
acromantula is that they're capable of
human speech yet they aren't self-taught
which indicates their ability to speak
was likely part of a magical breeding
process performed by a witcher wizard i
know totally weird right they're also
considered to be highly intelligent but
remain classified as beasts because
they're incapable of overcoming their
own brutal natures again this is all
according to newt's commander so if
acrimantula originated in borneo and are
bred by wizards would that mean that
aragog was the first acromantula in the
forbidden forest just outside the
hogwarts grounds well let's review his
conversation with harry and ron in
chamber of secrets now of course we all
know after following hagrid's advice to
follow the spiders harry ron and even
fang are captured and taken to aragog
and as they're talking to aragog they
learn a bit about his history here's
what he tells them i was not born in the
castle i come from a distant land a
traveler gave me to hagrid when i was an
egg hagrid was only a boy but he cared
for me hidden in a cupboard in the
castle feeding me on scraps from the
table hagrid is my good friend and a
good man when i was discovered and
blamed for the death of a girl he
protected me i have lived here in the
forest ever since where hagrid still
visits me he even found me a wife mosaic
and you see how our family has grown all
through hagrid's goodness and so from
the information we have there this
doesn't explicitly state that aragog was
the first acromantula in the forbidden
forest what we do know is that it would
appear there were no other females in
the forest at the time because hagrid
had to find him a wife but he also
doesn't make it clear that mosaic was
brought from outside the forest perhaps
mosaic was already there and hagrid
identified her as an ideal mate for
aragog i don't even want to begin
thinking about what hagrid would have
considered for such a thing but hey you
guys know how hagrid he did his own
thing when it came to magical beasts so
personally no i don't think it would
break the canon if acrimantula appear in
the forest in hogwarts legacy that being
said because they aren't native to the
area the story in hogwarts legacy would
definitely need to explain how these
acromantula got to the forest and i
think we already have a perfect
explanation for this with the poachers
that have been confirmed for hogwarts
legacy we've talked many times here
about the role magical creatures are
going to play in this game since the
very first trailer we've seen creatures
in chains wizards wearing animal skull
masks and in the recent autodesk
cutscene we saw a hippogriff being bound
and attacked with spells by a group of
dark wizards now remember that part from
earlier from fantastic beasts that i
said don't forget about the fact that
acromantula were possibly originally
bred to guard wizard dwellings or
treasure we already know one of the big
focuses of hogwarts legacy is going to
be on this so-called ancient magic and
it is my belief that this ancient magic
is not just going to be at hogwarts i
believe there are going to be other
areas outside of hogwarts where we will
be going and finding certain parts of
this ancient magic and one of the places
that you would expect to be a high
probability on that list as a holder of
this ancient magic could very well be
the forbidden force that would make
sense as a place to hide something
incredibly valuable and that brings us
back to the image that avalanche
recently shared beware spiders and it's
clear that having so many here on this
tree it is it's meant as a warning but
there are so many here i mean it almost
seems a little excessive right so was
this put here by the hogwarts staff or
was this actually put up by the group of
poachers as an extra precaution for what
acramantula may be guarding here again
my expectation is they're going to be
guarding one of these strongholds of
ancient magic now thanks to some resumes
from folks that were working on hogwarts
legacy we know there are going to be
various dungeons in the game and three
of those are expected to be referred to
as the castle dungeon goblin dungeon and
cairn dungeon goblin dungeon to me just
screams gringotts right i mean we've
already seen that in the trailer as well
castle dungeon that one's gonna be
somewhere at hogwarts but maybe it's
possible the cairn dungeon could be in
the forest or maybe the forest is
another dungeon entirely now as
terrifying as it will be to traverse
this area and have to take on these
spiders i love the nod to the original
series by including the acromantula here
i think all they need to do is come up
with a clever way of saying that maybe
the poachers brought the acromantula
there or maybe even someone specifically
brought them there just to guard
something but that is not the only nod
to the original series that appears to
be in hogwarts legacy in fact it seems
that we are going to be meeting a couple
of weasleys in this game one of them
possibly even a professor i break that
all down in the video on the right side
of your screen now as always thank you
all so much for watching i'll talk to
you again soon